hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the magnus carlson
invitational knockouts we are uh
still in the match magnus carlsen versus
yanni ponyshi and this
is now the tie break so magnus was able
to bounce back after
being lost for for the entire first day
and then uh
starting with a loss in the second day
magnus one game three and game four
bounced back and forced tie breaks and
now we are in the uh
tie breaks so the two blitz games will
be played and if those two blitz games
end in a draw
then we go into armageddon and this is
the second game of the
of the of the blitz mini match uh first
game ended in a draw it was quite a nice
one although a really weird one first
magnus was pushing for a win
in a completely drawn end game uh being
up a piece and then magnus blundered a
rook and then
nipple was pushing for a win it was
still of course completely raw but it's
super funny
uh so here uh magnus with the white
pieces uh everything is on him
if he can win with the white pieces then
he will be the winner and go into the
finals if nepo can
win then he goes or if it's a draw then
we go into armageddon so let's see what
happened here
magnus with the white pieces opens with
d4 he doesn't go for e4 and tries to go
for that sicilian that
they already played magnus won a very
nice game but he also figures that
probably nepo
uh figured when he went wrong and he's
not likely to repeat that so knight to
f6
uh we have c4 e6 and knight to c3
and now d5 striking in the center the
queen's gambit the client is on the
board
magnus straight once on d5 c captures e
captures and the bishop to g5 now
we have bishop to b4 nipple pins the
knight on c3 and
now e3 uh we have h6 again going
aggressively against carlson's bishop
bishop
to h4 and g5 we have bishop to g3 and
now knight to e for putting pressure on
the bishop and also a double attack on
the knight here
so knights to e2 magnus defense and now
h5 preparing
h4 to trap the bishop and this position
has been reached before h4 is the move
that's always played here
nepal himself had this position with the
white pieces last year in the russian
championship against moxie matlock of
the
dead game he won but magnus goes for h3
instead of h4
and this is now a new move so already as
of move 10 we have a completely new game
and nipple continues by eliminating uh
carlson's dark square bishop so knight
captures we have knight captures
and h4 grabbing more space on the king
side
forcing the knights to move and now
knight the h5 an
oddly strange uh square for the for the
knight
but if it works why not we have c6 nepo
strengthens the center here
and now bishop to e2 we have knights to
d7
now preparing knight to f6 the trade to
trade the knights and now
queen to b3 putting pressure on the
bishop here so near portrays we have
captures not
pawn captures but rather queen captures
and now knight to
f6 going for further trades we have
captures captures and now
a magnus goes for b4 and he wants to
play a4 and hone in on this weakness on
c6 well or rather
uh soon to be weakness so here a6 and
magnus pushes a4
now we have bishop to f5 just nicely
continuing development and
now magnus goes for a temporary pawn
sacrifice and pushes b5
you have to make weaknesses to exploit
them later on so a
captures on b5a captures and now nipple
castles
if you trade here captures captures it's
still very dangerous you you cannot win
a pawn just yet then queen to a8
check comes followed by queen captures
here here all of this is now weak
so instead after a captures on b5 we
have castles
and only now we have uh castles by white
and queen to e6 now so slowly but surely
improving the position uh
g4 might be an idea the queen and bishop
nicely aligned
with with the h3 pawn so rook f the c
one first again putting more pressure on
the pawn here and only now nipple
captures
c captures on b5 we have queen to b3
now uh aligning the queen with the pawn
getting ready to capture that and nipple
trades once we have captures captures
and rook the c8 bringing the rook to the
other open c
file to the other open file on the board
while still
being up upon and magnus doesn't go for
the pawn just yet he first goes bishop
to f3 puts pressure on the pawn here
bishop to e for defending and now bishop
characters we have queen captures by
nipple and now queen captures on b5
and we get this position where the
number of points is exactly the same but
magnus's position is to be preferred
as he only has one pawn island and nepo
has three pawn islands there's one
there's two there's three so it's going
to be easier to pick up
those pawns rook to c7 nipple starts by
defending this pawn and now
queen to b6 by magnus uh queen rook a8
check right away is interesting but it
doesn't seem to yield more than a draw
because after king g7
uh and rook to d8 trying to go after the
d5 pawn now we go rook to c1
check and after king to h2 queen to b1
and now
there's uh the only way to defend
checkmate is to trade queens and after
captures captures we're gonna capture on
d5
and get this position where uh yes white
is better but
uh how much better not not buy a lot
uh it's going to be this past pawn
against this pass pawn and the white
shouldn't really have any
realistic winning chances here so
instead after rook to c7 we have queen
to b6 putting pressure on the rook
uh and now queen to e7 defending uh both
rook and adding another defender to the
b7 pawn
queen to a5 now by magnus putting again
pressure on d5 and queen to d6 nipple
defends it while also improving the
position of his own queen
so rook to b1 by magnus and now king to
g7
we have queen to b5 and now b6 so slowly
but surely improving the position
point is you can never trade here
because if you capture here then rook to
c1 the deadly trick the king has no
escape squares you have to capture
and then you part with the queen so
queen captures on b6 and white would
resign here
so instead after after this b6 move we
have queen to d3 by magnus
and now queen to e6 we have queen back
to a6 and now nipple repeats queen to d6
he says i'm very happy with the draw
here
i have the black pieces let's go into
armageddon uh but
magnus says nope i'm not gonna not gonna
do that and again you cannot capture
here if you capture here then again you
get rook to c1 check and the h2 square
is covered so again you would lose the
queen you have to block
captures captures and then you even lose
the rook so instead after queen to d6 we
have queen back to e2 by magnus now and
the queen to g6 by airport now putting
pressure on the rook here on b1
so magnus moves at rook to a1 and now
queen to a4
uh we have queen back to b5 again
putting pressure here and now queen to
e6 nipple again defends we have queen to
b4
and now uh rook to c4 putting pressure
on the queen
queen back to b1 and now queen to c6 if
the rook now moves rook to c1 will be
deadly
so queen to f5 uh now going after the g5
pawn and here
rook the c1 check nipple now forces a
traitor rooks
uh and also uh goes into a queen and
pawn end game uh with the exact same
number uh
of pawns but nepo does have a past b
pawn and this is gonna be very scary to
defend
uh rook captures we have queen captures
uh with
czech king to h2 and now queen to c7
with check g3 and here h
captures and g3 would check now magnus
sidesteps this because
uh if you capture this then uh you don't
really gain anything just queen to e7
can be played the pawn is defended
you're going to start pushing this pawn
so magnus has to try something he tries
king to g2 now hoping to pick up the g5
pawn
uh but nepo defends it to just queen to
d8 the pawn
is now nicely defended both the g pawn
and this pawn and now he's gonna start
pushing his b
pawn and magnus seemingly without
counter play so here
king captures on g3 but now b5 uh we
have queen to b1
and now queen to d6 check aligning the
queen here to be able to push the pawn
so
king f3 and now b4 uh we have queen to
b3 magnus blocks the past pawn but now
queen to f6 with check king to g2
and now queen back to d6 defending the
pawn
king to g1 by magnus and now f6 uh the
pawn will help out with any
incoming checks also you can hide your
king on g6 king to g2
magnus now forced to repeat and now
nipple brings the queen into the attack
queen b6 now you're gonna go queen a5
queen a3 force the queen to move and
then continue pushing your past pawn
uh h4 magnus needs to create some sort
of an imbalance in the position in order
to
try and deliver some sort of a perpetual
checking idea
g captures on h4 and now king to h3 we
have queen to b5 now going for queen to
c4
and now king captures on h4 we have king
the
f7 by nipple and now king to g4 by
magnus king e6 now king to
f4 and now finally queen to c4
offering a trade and magnus goes back of
course queen to a4
you cannot trade here then it's just
lost we have b3
uh and here magnus goes for queen to e8
check now you have to continue checking
the black king if you stop doing that
uh your your game is over so king d6
magnus goes queen to b8 with
check we have king to c6 and here uh
magnus goes king to f5 and here
king to f5 is a bit a bit too ambitious
and uh
well uh king to f3 was the way to go
yeah this is no way to
to look for a win but it seems like
magnus really really wanted to look for
a win
with the white pieces and not allow the
game to go into armageddon but here
nipple just played queen to b5 and now
the problem is
after carlson played queen to c8 to
check king to b6
uh now you have queen to b8 to check and
now king to a5 the queens
are now cannot get traded off queen to
a7 check
king to b4 now we have queen to a1 and
now comes queen to e2
and this is the move that uh really
allows black to play for the move hence
a king to f3 f3 would prevent this move
and uh uh magnus would retain excellent
drawing chances but here
now there really is no no defense so
here king to e6 was played
but the just b2 forcing the the white
queen to move
if you go it doesn't really matter what
you do because if you go for something
like let's say queen to a7
uh then just be one queen and after you
play something like queen b7 check b
this queen can block it so that's not
happening so here after b2 magnus tried
the oldest trick in the book he played
queen to a6 offering a queen trade
uh but his queen is undefended so i
guess he was uh
hoping that nipple misses this and just
promotes the queen and then magnus wins
the queen on e2
but nepo just played queen captures on
a6 and it was
in this position that magnus carlsen
resigned the game because he's now
queenless he's in check
and nippo is also bringing another queen
into the game
so really really a wild a while the
semifinal match almost
almost as if it was uh some sort of a
great great
story you know told in uh you know in a
trilogy or or two trilogies even uh
because it was a really uh
incredible day one and an incredible day
too everyone thought nepal would just
take it away but then
magnus bounced back uh retaliated one
game three and four then they
forced the tie breaks and then uh you
know it all came down to this where
magnus wanted to push for a win with the
white pieces to avoid armageddon
uh but it seems those those russians
really know their end games
so a very tough break for magnus but an
excellent opportunity for nippo
to win the entire thing and become the
winner of the magnus crossing
invitational
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh sorry about so many videos today
but
the games were crazy and you know a lot
of them were played we're gonna of
course check the other match as well as
uh there was a lot of excitement in
there but you know i'm only one person i
can't cover everything
you know at the same time uh so yeah
i hope you guys enjoyed it once again uh
and uh yeah uh i would like to thank
david kimura nicolas verkos uh peter
smith
hannah arndt and now faltemar for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
magnus cross and invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day